let's jump to this story from the Daily
Mail quote why did you ask such a dumb
question but in snaps at reporter who
asks him why he's referred to as quote
the big guy in FBI Ukraine file it's
obviously because I'm taking the money
idiot what is the quickest verbal moment
while in offense yeah right the fancy
never responded oh man I've said this a
million times before but it was so it
was so pathetic the way the media was
trying to position this man as a kind
caring adult right oh Trump's the nasty
one and Biden's nice no no no Biden's
nasty he's just not funny like his
cancer
let me give you this this important
context I say the nickname was revealed
in an FBI memo that Republicans claim
proves Biden was at the center of a five
million dollar cash for influence
bribery scheme when he was vice
president if the memo shows that their
informant called Biden the big guy I
mean that's corroboration that is that
is crazy so yeah I don't know how you
get around that and that will be the
example I used before of media Omission
I I guess we could pull up the sites
right now but I guarantee you on
washingtonpost.com there's not a mention
to that on newyorktimes.com there's just
no mention of this memo there's no
mention of the big guy they'll just
ignore the story no they're just going
back and stealth editing old articles
about Biden being like Biden who gets
colloquially called the big guy by
everybody who's called the big guy by
his son
in high school you know no way yeah so
this is hilarious I think the campaign
was trying to get out in front of this
because there was a little picture book
published ostensibly for children about
Joe Biden and it mentioned his time in
high school and it says he was such a
good football player and he'd always
catch the ball so they called him hands
I'm like like that's not what that's not
what it's called I think you just know
that they were waiting for someone who
went to high school with him to be like
we called that guy hands he was weird
football man besmirched the good name of
Corn Pop yeah Corn Pop was a good dude
who ran a bunch of good boys that story
about Corn Pop when Joe Biden talks
about how he's at the pool and the kids
are rubbing his legs corn pot was
probably like stop touching those kids
dude yeah no he wouldn't get off the
diving board I don't buy it I think he
was talking to those kids in Corn Pop
look at look at what he says about his
his first wife's death he he he says
that the guy who the truck driver was
drunk he wasn't remotely drunk he just
made up that story to make his wife more
sympathetic he was drinking his lunch
that day the truck driver's family sued
him wow for like a cease and desist
because they said like our dad was not a
drunk our dad wasn't drunk it was a
terrible car accident a lot of people
think maybe Mrs Biden was the drunk one
but I guess that will be a a autopsy
that it ever had but he has no problem
besmirching the good name of of
individuals if it helps his career so
he's not a good person he's
a terrible person if you're the kind of
person who doesn't mind being on camera
groping children they'll I really don't
think he's worried about life like what
is no just sniffing children in
public in front of ever like that's a
disgusting horrible thing to do and then
on top of that it's not of the
self-awareness to know like hey
everyone's watching me while I'm doing
this horrible disgusting Slinky thing
doesn't care he's like I can get away
with it yeah
no he's a very strong do you think he
sniffs his legs ever because of the hair
he's got a thing for it I imagine that
like when corn pop confronted Joe Biden
and was like you gotta stop touching
those kids man and then he grabs the
chain or whatever he had to change no no
so Bill Wright Mouse he was the only
white guy in the air and he did all the
pools and he brought me it worked showed
me all the mechanics where all the pool
of a filter is and uh he cut me off a
link to chain there was a chain that
went across the pool for the Deep edit
he cut him off the chain and he said you
tell Corn Pop That if you you may cut me
man but I'm gonna wrap this chain around
your head and if you don't tell him that
then don't come back and he was right so
Joe Biden because these are the words of
Joe Biden's got a chain this is Joe
Biden you memorize that speech very well
candies yeah that's the most famous
president so it speaks to me it's like
the Gettysburg Address so Corn Pop is
confronting Joe Biden is abusing kids
yeah and then down the line people
actually take this story seriously that
cone pops the bad guy knowing the
history of Joe Biden I am convinced that
Corn Pop was probably a local kid who
saw Joe Biden groping kids and said yo
we're gonna put a stop to this him and
his buddies and he's like there's a
couple of bad dude there's bad boys it's
like probably some local kids who are
like yo this lifeguard keeps groping
kids yeah make a make a cartoon about
what really happened what really
happened it was a good dude I got a
bunch of good boys and one day seriously
they'll make up make a cartoon of the
true story we did and then animated but
take the statement of him yeah but not
not Joe Biden right now that's not
reliable the version where he's like the
kids are touching my legs what actually
happened yeah and the guy's like you
better knock it off Joe you creepy hands
hey hands stop groping those kids they
call me that cause of football what are
you talking about catching footballs
hands big guy Joe Biden I was dying
because here's the thing no one has
alleged that he was called hands before
and then they published this little
picture book that says he was called
Hans Biden in high school I'm like that
is not what they call them it's not
because he was good at catching
footballs
they're gonna write that as as a child
Hunter no they're gonna say uh uh Beau
Biden called him the big guy because
then they're gonna make it like don't
insult his yeah you can't question Beau
at all who died in Iraq that's right
yeah tragically yeah one woman people
brought Hunter up to Joe they were
talking about his son he's like Bo is a
great kid dude if somebody started like
bringing up bad things I had done to my
father like how do you speak like how do
you speak to the fact that your son does
X Y and Z and then he started like
singing my brother's Praises I'd be like
oh my dad must be really embarrassed of
me yeah right well I think Joe Biden
knows if he if he brings a bow he can
deflect anything because people don't
want to comment on that right they don't
talk about it he says the craziest
anything do you remember when his
daughter's Diaries got leaked and she
just obviously is a very troubled person
and you have to wonder at what point did
she become very troubled uh as she and
her brother both abuse a lot of drugs
drugs they have very serious issues and
they both grow up in the same household
so it's almost like there was a bad
influence in and around the household
they grew up in yeah like I don't
understand how we can think Joe Biden is
a good guy and just got really
unfortunate with these two super
privileged children who both are just
trying but nobody does no but nobody
thinks he's a good guy Democrats are
lying about everything that's true you
know it's like you you talk to people on
the right and they'll make fun of trump
they'll say stuff like what what's the
joke where uh Sheamus I think you made
it that Trump is a is like uh uh he's
like a street cred because he's got
three baby mamas oh yeah we did a
cartoon on that he has three baby mamas
and a criminal record like he the girls
love him now like people on the right
have no problem pointing out they know
these things about Trump there are
negative things about Trump but there
are reasons they like it people on the
left will defend literally anything
Biden does well no I'm sorry I'm sorry I
should clarify that many leftists won't
but they'll still vote for him that's I
I get that but there are liberals who in
the media the corporate neolibs are the
ones I'm actually talking about who no
matter what he does they will lie and
defend him
yeah well and that's the thing people
will talk about Donald Trump and they'll
say how could you Christians vote for
this man who's behaved in such an
unchristian way oh my goodness I forgot
all of these wonderful opportunities I
have to vote for good Christians in
politics who do good Christian things
all the time it's completely nonsense
like when when was there ever this
option of wonderful virtuous people to
pick from in American politics in my
lifetime there was it you know what's
great about Donald Trump he doesn't hate
me he doesn't hate me like every other
person I've had the opportunity to vote
for does so you voted for people who
hate you no I I didn't vote for those
people because the first presidential
election I was old enough to vote in was
Trump versus Hillary oh yeah
we don't have to talk about it no yeah
yeah well this was also back when I was
uh still living in Cook County right so
my vote wasn't going to do anything but
I still voted for him
yeah you weren't with her believe it or
not I I did think it was her turn but I
thought this is Cook County my vote
won't mean anything he has a joke he
voted for Trump I voted for him
wholeheartedly I was still living in DC
in 16 and we joked when the results came
in and Trump had like 4 500 and
something votes and we were like I bet
you we know all of those people
are like six degrees of separation like
we could probably figure out who they
are you're all at the same election
it's us guys so so uh what do you think
is gonna happen you think uh
you think Trump gets the nomination goes
goes up against Biden then wins or what
oh yeah I'll let you make the prediction
yeah well I think Biden has a I don't I
won't say if it's that cut and dry
um I don't think it's going to be 20 20
all over again because Biden has a
record to run on
um ultimately if you want to think I'm a
conspiracy theorist Lunas lunatic which
I am
um they have to find the covet variant
by 2024. but it can't be covered bird
flu whatever it is they have to go back
to mail-in ballots they have to go back
to bird flu they have to they they can't
win any other way or you don't think
it's gonna be a monkey pox surge it
could be wildfires it could be something
some pandemic has to happen that they
can control the balloting uh at the
local level because it's the only way
he's gonna something has to stop people
from being able to have fun yeah yeah
absolutely and there are just too many
and people like what about the Suburban
housewife the Suburban housewife is
tired of paying 475 for a dozen eggs and
she doesn't like Trump but she's really
really broke now look all that matters
is the Republicans political action
committees you name it whether it's
Trump or not they're going to run ads of
the trans activists bouncing their their
topless breasts at the White House yeah
and so and they're going to run those in
the suburbs non-stop they have to and
then Suburban moms are going to be like
oh no yep and and and calling those
parents domestic terrorists yeah you
know that's that's the type of stuff so
if you're going to go after our kids
then then we're going to use our kids to
go after you thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time